for me
whoever you edify and lift up people
will do what that person is doing so for
example
in a sales company for us
whoever you i'll always say you give me
the number one person of any company
i'll tell you the future the company
next five to ten years
based on who the number one is not who
number two is
who the number one is you're meaning no
not ceo
the sales company you got you got a
thousand sales player the sales
sales so sales leaders sales people yeah
but whoever the number one is anytime i
chose a number one that was more about
them
than the team the company collapsed
every time but if you chose the right
number one the company
exploded like sapalas they took the
company a whole different level we've
had great number ones guyton sappala
we've had a lot of different number ones
right and they're all great number ones
because people want to be like
well okay can i get that kind of
recognition yes like we're about to play
we're going to vegas tomorrow we're
going to have 12 000 people i'm on the
phone last time with mario lopez because
he's hosting awards ceremony nikki jam
sebastian
mike tyson it's going to be pretty
intense even next week in vegas for a
whole week at mgm grand
but whoever your number one is people
are going to duplicate so now
you go back 50 years ago in america who
was the hero in america 50 years ago jfk
okay who else yeah i'm with that john
wayne go
go 50 years ago it's actually 20 71.
1971. after that 1971 was that
just died 1971
who was the richest man in america in
who was it who was a cow pull it up and
see who was it was lee iacocca there you
go uh
i don't know 1971 is probably going to
be a it has to be it has to be forward
it has to be somebody
for those guys richest man in the world
in 1970
okay so so there you go this was so
think about that sinatra
howard hughes howard hughes was one of
them sam walton okay
yeah walton was getting started daniel
ludwig it's an interesting story
okay so keep going frank sinatra
everybody wants to be like frank elvis
okay elvis you want to be like elvis
great who else did you want to be like
uh that's clint eastwood really getting
into uh his his uh
his john wayne 71 the counter culture
was really big too you were starting to
get um
i mean it was really by the way look at
that there's howard hughes so you look
at howard hughes
j paul getty was prior to that okay okay
i'm thinking
one of the great chamberlain kareem
abdul-jabbar
one of the greatest independence ever
called easy rider by dennis hopper
and peter fonda and jack nicholson 1970
perfect jack nicholson was the face of
hollywood i thought was he one of the
guys peter fond the president okay
so 71. fair so this the beatles were
huge the beatles were huge in 71. okay
so
if you're 18 years if you're 14 to 18
years old and you're in high school like
oh my gosh bro i'd love to be like in
baseball it was who 71 to be
basketball was kareem 71 baseball would
be aaron
the end of medicare aaron yeah aaron
let's just say you're looking up to
mickey mountain you're looking up to
aaron right okay
so so these are the heroes we looked up
to right
at that time so kid is competing to be
who
that person okay kid is trying to be
like that person
who's the hero today in america lebron
james who else
well that's one of them but give me some
of the names heroes
heroes heroes who's
you think people look at leo like they
want to be like this
if you're talking about the 14 to 18 age
range you've got to talk about youtube i
was just about to say
you got to talk about youtube paul
brothers yeah paul brothers pewdiepie
pewdiepie who else mr beast mr
yeah yeah so so let me ask you a
question let me go to a different part
here so in 1971
what does a man's man look like in 1971
manly
uh
frank sinatra you know somebody like
that was a man's man and he pulled
something out you wanted to be like a
man's man
in the in the 70s right okay what does a
man's man look like today
what is a man's manta is that even an
insult to say a man's man what's a man's
mouth i think a man's man
looks similar but i don't know if a
man's man is what's being pushed to the
mainstream if that makes sense
is a man's man likely to be on the cover
of a time magazine today is a man's man
likely to be the hero today is a man's
man likely to be someone we look up to
today no no no they they they're pre
precisely the opposite they're presented
as like being somehow repressive of
other people like
you know if you somehow are working a
lot and earning
you can't earn a good living for
yourself without somehow oppressing
somebody else
yeah you're they literally call it toxic
masculinity so okay so let's talk about
a rich person in 1971 if you were rich
did people want to know who the
lives of rich and famous was first was
it like oh my gosh
the lifestyles of the rich and famous
okay so it was cool to be rich in the
70s
what is it today to be rich i talk about
it all the time what is the thing i hate
most about our culture is the repentant
rich
but what i'm saying to you is like today
not even the repentant rich i'm talking
the 14 to 18 year old is he looking up
saying dude i admire these rich people i
want to be like
well there was a study that came out um
a poll they yeah they pulled
people under 21 their thoughts on
capitalism versus socialism
it was like shocking i think 54
said that capitalism was bad and 44 said
yeah
so younger people are not advocates of
capitalism yeah but they both
i bet you most of the people taking that
poll cannot define either of those and
that was actually the part b to that
is that they actually asked the
follow-up question like would you know
the difference and they're like
not really no socialism sounds i mean
the word sounds nice like
it rolls off the tongue nicely it's got
the word social in it sounds great
you know who doesn't like being social
social media capital sounds social
security yeah yeah but but again i think
i think this is a
we've we've forgotten who the hero is
can i show you a picture we are we are
edifying the wrong hero so these kids
have the wrong
image of who to look up to because i
don't care who you admire
but i at least want to have somebody i
put up there to say
hey one day what if one day you know
this is a man's man this is an example
of one day for us to be alive i'm gonna
show you a picture because that's
actually a great point it's a great i
pulled this picture up
this is trending on on social media and
it's basically
back in my day this was now your
generation
exactly so i see that it's freaking
hilarious the original nas versus little
nausea listen i i actually
look there's i have an interesting thing
you actually have that out i have an
interesting thought about it
see with little nozzles if you look at
at like the people in the
like the 1700s 1800s 18th century right
these are some of the toughest human
beings on planet earth and they dressed
like that yeah
like the laws of chivalry had to be
invented because people were just
murking each other it was like say
something wrong about me and we'll have
a duel
and i'd shoot you in the face but i'd
walk around looking like that
but then we'd kill each other over an
argument i think
i would have loved it i think we need
better heroes
how about we just don't need to tear
them down we forget having better heroes
yeah it would be great can we just start
by not tearing down the heroes that we
already have so
tearing down statues so yesterday this
week i spoke to a guy named ken ishu
who wrote the book called the
inconvenient minority
and he talks about how there's this high
school called the thomas jefferson high
school it's the number one high school
in america
best grades kids come out there 76
percent of the school is asian
okay seventy seven nearly nearly eighty
percent
what city is this in i don't know if you
look it up he was talking about thomas
jefferson high school
and then he talks about how in harvard
out of all the applicants that submit
their applications
they should accept 43 43 of harvard
should be asian
but only 21 is because they want to make
sure they're inclusive you know the
whole
you know making sure we're accepting
discriminate against they don't want too
many asians there because it's way too
much
out of 5.9 in america asian our
population is 5.9
asian 22 percent of harvard
students are asian okay so out of only
5.9
to 22 of harvard so they're just
completely rocking it right
yeah and you know he's talking about
what's going on why he didn't want to go
to harvard et cetera and yesterday i
talked to eddie gallagher i don't know
if you know eddie gallagher's eddie
gallagher is a
he's the guy that was the navy seal he
did eight tours two bronze medals and
he was seen with the video with one of
the isis terrorists that they took the
picture in the video and it went viral
he went to prison
you know this story yeah chief eddie
gallagher navy seal and then trump uh
got him he says i don't i don't support
what he did but i think a man that put
his life out he's got to get out
and i said tell me what it's like in the
military the military has something
called the
navy and cis okay it's like the
intelligence where they do research
literally a tv show called nci yeah if
you can pull out what ncis means and
then there's cid
ncis and cid are the same thing i said
what role does ncis place he said
he says who runs ncis he says well it's
the officers and i said okay
so why don't officers support what
you're doing he says because
you know for them they don't they don't
like us so i went to google
i said let me look up navy seal because
when you think about a man's band what
do you think about
you think about when you if i told you
right now he's a navy seal what would
you say
how would you look at him if i told you
to navy strong masculine brave
courageous you look at him in a
different way i look at him now he's not
a navy seal he just goes to the beach a
lot but
you know so but if i said navy seal you
immediately judge him so i looked up how
many people are navy seals in america
today
2 500. how many active billionaires do
we have in america today
around the same number 2500 okay he said
ncis hates
anybody that makes it to the highest
level like navy seals
so who writes about billionaires that
they don't like them
you got regulators like an elizabeth
warren you've got some journalists that
go after them
the cid and regulators they're the same
human beings he said the most
interesting thing to me yesterday
because general miller i asked him about
general milley
i said so what happened with general
miller talking about crt and here's a
general like why is a general
going out there defending some of these
things being taught he says because
there's an interesting thing that you
don't know about it so what's that
he says in the military after 04 or o5
to get your promotion congress has to
sign off on your promotion
let me say this one more time so if
you're a politician
politicians have to sign off if you
become a colonel
or a general one star general you need
congress
to sign off on your promotion
interesting this is gallagher is saying
this to me on the podcast we did yes he
has a book that just came out called
he's got a book coming out with the
interview's going to come out here next
week so
the point is the people who are not the
man's man
are in charge of building up who the
man's man is
so up until that changes we are never
going to recognize who the management is
we are never going to recognize who the
real heroes are
so the problem isn't that the problem is
who's telling the world
who the real heroes are on a small level
a much smaller level than that that's an
incredible story
and also if we can find a crossover
between the 2 500
uh navy seals and 2 500 billionaires we
have batman so if we find one that's
well
but the the interesting thing about what
you're saying is there's actually a guy
who listens to the show
who is pushing back on that and that's
curt schilling kurt schilling whether
you agree with him or don't agree with
him kurt schilling is a very great uh
american baseball pitcher bloody suck
bloody sock incredible competitor
tough guy tough dude but he made some uh
to to you know our our establishment
some
some questionable tweets while he was
working for espn and now he has
requested to be taken
off the hall of fame yeah
he's almost a lock to make it this year
and he's been requested to be taken off
the ballot
because he does not want to give the
writers the the
the ability to judge his career you
don't get to tell me whether or not i
was a hall of famer
he'll wait the seven years until he goes
to the veterans committee which is a
bunch of old players
that select people that that haven't
gone through the process
and he's like i would rather wait and
then have my peers put me in the hall of
fame
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye